all right so i wanted to do this video
on
what i actually eat on a given day
now the reason why i'm hesitant to do
this video is simply because
um it's nothing exciting and um
you know i'm not your average person i
can eat the same thing
every single day my wife has to have
variety
i don't i primarily eat for health most
people
don't eat for health so realize when i
tell you this
this is just what i eat you can eat
whatever you want to eat just make sure
it's keto friendly
when most people start keto they do need
desserts they need variety to keep it
interesting
so realize this is just a kind of a
an example of what i eat now presently i
eat one and a half meals a day
i'm going to tell you why i would
normally
eat one meal a day but if i do that i
tend to lose a little too much weight
and it's very difficult for me to
consume the amount of calories in one
meal so i kind of spread it out so it's
not two full meals it's like one and a
half
the first meal is between one to two
o'clock
okay in the afternoon and the second
meal is between
five and six o'clock p.m
so that gives me kind of a fasting range
between 19 hours
and 21 hours now i also want to
differentiate the difference between
keto and healthy keto keto basically is
just low carbs they're not focused on
the nutrition okay the nutrients
the benefit is from the lowering of your
carbs
healthy keto factors in the
nutrient-dense
foods okay and this is why i recommend
the healthy keto plan
with this x factor called intermittent
fasting seems to work great
on pretty much everyone all right what
do i eat in the first
meal i consume a combination of
protein and fat mostly some vegetables
but not too much
i may do four eggs with onions with some
fermented veggies
and so i get these fermented veggies
from the farmer's market
sometimes i get them from amazon and
make sure that they don't have sugar in
them
i might also do asparagus and i'll just
have that raw and i'll just chew on like
maybe five
uh five little stalks of asparagus
now realize someone took my video out of
context and they said
dr berg eats all this food in one meal
which is not true so
when i give you these examples you're
not supposed to add them up okay i don't
eat all of these this is
four eggs onions slash fermented
vegetables
or hamburger half a pound
but not both together okay so i just
want to clarify that
now i consume a lot of hamburger why
because hamburger is a lot
more fatty than steak and i
never buy the 90 lean i buy the 75 to 80
so it's more fatty i'll consume about
half a pound with sauerkraut
so that would be my protein i make sure
that it's grass-fed grass-finished
and a bit fatty i do buy a lot of my
hamburger from u.s wellness
meats i don't get any commission off
that fyi
now another option i might consume
especially if i'm in a rush
is summer sausage i found one that has
less than one gram of sugar okay and i
put the link down below it's pretty good
and it's all organic so that's good it's
very hard to find summer sausage
without having some dextrose or other
types of sugar in
it and i'll i will consume about eight
ounces of that
okay it's very fast i'll cut it up and
sometimes i'll add cheese to it
maybe i'll have some swiss cheese the
cheese is always grass-fed
organic and primarily from
europe it's not velveeta
okay now other times i'll have some
salmon
i'm very very spoiled with salmon
because sometimes you get this salmon
that's old or it's um
if you go to a restaurant it's
overcooked and it just doesn't taste
that great
so i make my own salmon and i just fry
it
with olive oil put sea salt and pepper
and then i'll put mayo i like the primal
kitchen mail because
it doesn't have any sugar and the oil is
avocado oil and that's what i'll consume
and sometimes i'll add olives to my meal
i like olives
so that's pretty much what i eat now
right after the meal
i might add some pecans because i might
not be satisfied so
maybe a handful of pecans sometimes
i'll do celery and peanut butter the
peanut butter is organic valencia
salted i get that from trader joe's i've
done videos on that it's a pretty good
peanut butter
and sometimes i'll add a little
chocolate now of course this is
sugar-free chocolate
there's a lot of different keto friendly
chocolate things out there
the one that i like now is just with
chocolate
and stevia i'll put a link down below of
a few
you may not like these because when you
sweeten chocolate with stevia it gives
you this little aftertaste
which i don't seem to mind karen won't
consume it so
she does lily's chocolate which is
a little bit tastier but i find that
that throws off my digestive system
if i have chocolate with just stevia it
doesn't bother my digestive system
at all and i'll just do like three
ounces of that chocolate
okay so now that's the simplicity of
what i eat
for my first meal second meal all right
i will
primarily start with the veggies okay
usually eight cups of salad sometimes
seven sometimes ten
but it's this bowl of salad i'll start
eating that
i like to use arugula or a greens mix
from the farmer's market simply because
sometimes the salad that you buy at the
grocery store is just
completely empty the ideal situation
would be to have you consume salad from
your own garden
i'm going to do some videos on that that
would be the best thing because you can
control
how much nutrition that's in that salad
i really believe that people do not like
salad because they've never
tasted really good salad grown on really
good soils
so i highly recommend you seek out some
good salad so you can taste what it
normally should taste like
okay now i put some sea salt on my salad
i might add avocado
maybe some nuts but not too many other
things
i use a lot of olive oil but not your
regular olive oil
i get my olive oil from italy i'm sure
there's
other types of olive oil out there but
just make sure it's fresh
because most the olive oil out there
doesn't even taste like anything it
should have a very
fresh almost like a grass-cut taste
kind of a little spicy so i just dump a
lot of olive oil on there and i'll put
balsamic
vinaigrette okay that's all i use now i
may have a different type of salad
uh chopped cabbage and carrot
okay and i use a combination of white
cabbage and red cabbage
i have one of those little choppers that
i just put in there and i chop it down
and if i'm doing that i'm not gonna do
eight cups i'm gonna do like three and a
half cups
because it's very dense and i'll put
some mayo on it from primal kitchen
and i just love that that seems to
really digest well
and that would be my vegetable for the
day now sometimes i might just do a
steamed cauliflower
four cups with a lot of butter and sea
salt and pepper
all right do i add any protein
occasionally sometimes i'll do like a
half a can of cod liver not
cod liver oil but cod liver you can
search it it's out there it's pretty
awesome
most of it's wild caught and it's not
bad tasting and it's
very high in fat and it has some protein
in there not too much
if you do a whole can of cod liver
you're going to be very filled up
and sometimes i do that as well
depending on
if i've exercised very intensely and i
need to eat more
now i also might add some summer sausage
not eight ounces but maybe four ounces
okay it's really quick it gives me a
little protein and maybe i'll put a
little swiss cheese with that
i may add some pecans i may add celery
with that
peanut butter i mentioned um just until
i'm satisfied
okay so that's pretty much what i
eat now what do i fry the eggs in beef
tallow
where do i get my greens preferably from
the farmer's market if i can
sometimes i can't go there so i will
just buy the arugula
from the store it has to be organic
of course and when tomatoes are in
season i will consume a tremendous
amount of
tomatoes from the farmer's market or i
will consume them from the garden
but i will not consume a tomato unless
it's
a good tasting one which means that it
has a lot of nutrition
all right guys so there you have it
that's what i eat pretty boring but
it's workable hey before you go real
quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here
what about strengthening your immune
system
that's what's missing this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today